hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to warframe now this is a
free game that is extremely in-depth has
been built for years expanded upon and I
know next to nothing about it but I'm
gonna play it because no teams cool I
like space I like robots I like science
I like all these things Excalibur a
perfect balance of mobility and offense
Excalibur is yet ideal warframe for new
players
well that's me baby with a full command
of surrounding magnetic energy mag is an
expert at enemy manipulation that seems
interesting I guess volt can create and
harness electrical elements this is for
a high damage warframe perfect for
players who want a potent alternative to
gunplay well I mean I'm a basic [ __ ] so
I guess I'd have to go with the basic
[ __ ] warframe also disclaimer like I
said I'm new to this game so it's gonna
take me a bit to get used to it I mean
I'm pretty good with the shoe sting in
the would not but when it comes down to
the deeper details of this game it's
probably gonna take me a bit so what
you're about to see is a arduous journey
of me persevering against all odds and
trying to survive and struggle against
everything oh that's bad for the knees
that's bad for the knees to suddenly go
from hibernation to slamming down on my
leg 'yes yes ok well says you
oh well that's just gross No
we are taking this one with us yeah you
stupid idiots oh hey cool thank you
I'll use my power alright yeah okay
did I do it really smash those guys in
the pits hey that's not nice sorry
alright well it did that so uh so what
about that they're all way more rude oh
man you really should have thought about
this a little further
like a warframe power that's nice I also
got a thing on my leg like a tattoo I
guess you say it's funny that they're
called the Grenier they don't seem to be
smiling too much I know how to sprint
and jump
melee weapon who shatters armor with
heavy blows I like heavy blow slices
through enemies with this agile
warrior's blade I'm a basic [ __ ] like I
said I'm gonna go with the big heavy
thing oh yeah I like muck mukha bow my
m'kay bow all right let's do you're done
zone now buddies whomp yeah man this
game looks amazing for being free oh
wait what that sayi warframe is out of
power
we're frame out of power yeah that was
the least stealthy attack I've ever seen
I pulled my weapon through that guy's
body for go stealth with this rapid-fire
semi-automatic pistol or silently
puncture flesh and metal with these
deadly throwing knives what am i some
kind of [ __ ] metal ninja
give me the loud boom banger give me the
bigger the bang of the Boomer I like
that shoes yeah yeah there we go that's
a good bang well I think for me I think
for might have found out I escaped to do
yeah unnecessary but I like it you is
the only way I'm not move now oh I can
double jump all right well I can do that
melee attack with E oh then what was it
it was one and whatever stealth attack
tell the text for babies hey sorry yeah
I'm just gonna go ahead first in boom oh
I saw red not those I like building
myself I like being diverse and
effective I think whoa hello hi I'm here
it's me handsome man or machine cool
beans for two seconds and I loved him
now screw you buddy you're about to get
a face full of bullet in a whole lot of
this oh hey wait how did I do that again
I've forgotten already
wait how do I forgotten how to do this
ticket how do I
I've forgotten already how do I I did
the thing where I was spinning it like
I'll do duty oh there we go
I'm spinning I'm spinning oh wait no I
just got a block if that's right yeah
okay all right sorry oh he's my favorite
thing I've ever done oh hey how's it
going for you okay sure sure thing buddy
my name is markiplier if you could just
call me by my real name that'd be
greatly appreciated this is the best way
to move on Wow oh [ __ ] oh yeah I'm sorry
oh yeah I barely remember how to - okay
okay so mobility is a big part of this
game I get it I get it whoopsies sorry
didn't know I had to reload it now
whatever what is this yes give me the
biggest what ever is a bow you owe me a
place gaming with a freakin o do you
think I am some kind of loser some kind
of rogue wolf sneaking up with my
enemies oh no I don't want them to see
me I'm so scared about ugly I am I'm
still be the gun no I'm gonna shoot him
in the face I want them to see my
handsome face and be ashamed of how ugly
they are in comparison to me and then
blow their head off that's what I do
thank you
[Music]
what do you even have nuts all right
whatever it's also massively multiplayer
I haven't gotten to that part yet I
think that guy's name was balls hey are
you doing hello what is this how you
disengage it all I know is death sorry
fine a new hope now all right that's
that's a funky hacking system mm-hmm I
don't think so man I don't think so
your old eyes are stupid and old my
young eyes are probably young and
vibrant and full of beauty just look at
my face and see how handsome I am
Oh guru but oh wow I sure can do some
flips wah wah wah wah and I don't think
so oh I guess I think so well I was
having a great time I was having a good
time by myself you were having a good
time sucking eggs over there - I figured
that it'd probably do something like
that well then that was an awfully
explosive tutorial sequence and this
game's cool I'm aware I'm very complex
up here
why is my left leg glowing and my crotch
is kind of radiating some ethereal
glowing pulses but hey that's just a
factor of who I am I'm special throwing
throw special all the way thanks for
whatever this is if it's money I think
you have returned I am orders ship
Cephalon a shadow of my former self I
cannot serve the operator in such a
condition order me to self-destruct I
will understand okay blow yourself up
for this old technology it is superior
to theirs
perhaps there are systems left in the
orbiter compartment wait no hang on I
gotta I gotta order this guy to blow
himself up I don't know maybe you were
kind of annoying that's really funny
live my favorite thing I did it I fixed
up what the thing and the thing I'm a
genius very complex up here man you got
some kind of BDSM kick going on here
okay hang on I gotta look at my ortus is
right but ortus was still ordered to
blow himself up it hurt his it blow
itself up I don't know
Excalibur unranked cool unranked I don't
know what unranked means but uh wait
that's not my money wait what is that
then that's the same gun you're not
fooling me that's the same gun you can't
fool me on spending anything to anybody
that's same gun whoa where did that come
from
Oh time to go in this place oh god I got
earth okay I've got earth I've got all
of earth restore ship comms
all righty then okay this is where I
think I'm gonna get into the multiplayer
compartment of this because I think it
just adds you to other games now I don't
know if there's gonna be open mic so I
might just start screaming at other
people at random which is usually what I
do when it comes down to these
multiplayer games like this I don't know
if it's Auto percent true but that's
what I think is gonna happen
thunk but a lot Bob a da da da da huh oh
this is it oh well that's hardly a hack
at all my camera what the hell happened
like that hang on oh you're talking to
me but I just don't care Oh
nobody will ever know okay go and start
ah there I am okay I'm back everybody
thanks I know you missed me okay Here I
am
okay hello you alright yeah sorry man
you just you're just stupid I don't know
what to tell you about that those are
dumb of you halt
well the mobility part of this game is
what makes it really interesting like
the fact that I'm able to zip zap Zoop
everywhere is really really interesting
I love hey sorry buddy couldn't see over
there what it killed you sooner but I
didn't and they both are here oh I know
I could resources oh I didn't see that
on the way in did I well poop alright
well poop that and poop me oh these like
mods oh I think they're mods okay those
are those have got to be like mod of
course corpus I know that I know what
that is I put the thing in the thing
again I put it in you got you got a
little bipolar going on with you
[Music]
connected with other Tenno in the system
the operator may now contact all black
market
scumbags contact arms dealers boyo the
problem with their with authority and I
love it
10 oh we need to make contact with a
corpus defector sympathetic to the Tenno
cause they will of course require
compensation ok this is referring to
operator no this case compensation well
not to be credits it will be freedom
I love dated navigation you will need to
break him out of a Grenier go leg ok a
GU leg
I knew it these were space Russians
that's what I knew it there's space
Russians we gotta bust him out of the
gulag don't think I don't know that
we're talking about space Russians here
space Soviets and whatnot I'm talking
about space for who is who are you can
you hear me hello please tell me it's no
anyway I got a party member down
oh he's cooler than I am wait oh there I
am
can I get through here thank you kind of
left my teammate behind I guess I don't
know if they can hear me
I don't know if I've just been shouting
at them but whatever ok here we go
yeah man you really shouldn't have run
ahead without your schema kids just like
me I guess same thing oh really
do we really need the both of us oh oh
there you are
there you are okay they're just as good
as me as navigation there we go all
right let's do this
Leroy what I have not been spotted I
didn't do [ __ ] okay huh huh okay
Darville out I didn't hear that last
part but I'm assume that it's not as
important there we go the asker as you
say okay Dara whatever you want buddy
avoid taking damage I don't know if
those words mean all I know is damage
and I do a lot of that bet it whoa
almost manic nugget it died didn't make
it okay well I thought I was gonna make
it then I didn't make it oh come on
yeah can I say pretty good pretty good
pretty good
wall wall wall and I know what that
means pretty damn good look at me look
at me my head what do I got oh yeah
that's a good one I don't know what this
is for fusion
okay I need to I was in the wrong place
okay okay okay all right there we go I
installed the mod I think oh [ __ ] okay
well I got it then yeah what is that
noise
this hole is meant for me this hole is
mine it's been for me it's meant for me
it's my hole the mystery of a Megara
fault anybody know that all right how do
I leave this group
is ready for installation operator
what'd you say did you say something
crazy crazy order says what okay do I
need to put the thing into thing again
here we go putting the thing in the
thing I push the button all I did was
push the button that time I didn't even
get to put a thing in the thing I just
put the button in that thing oh no
operator our component storage has been
looted as well it's almost physically
took everything yeah sure the blueprint
is free operator print ok countermeasure
to what by the way Oh to the thing
that's creeping up my spine that's what
the thing that you were talking about
was you can go straight operator I am
sorry what are you talking about your
mother eating something or not it's got
personality I think because I'm a robot
I don't have you actually have to worry
about the cold unless I'm not a robot
I'm a robot I don't even know if I'm a
robot or not oh well whatever here we go
hello here to bash your door but now I'm
like I'm gonna kick myself because all
those green locker looking things that I
thought I could open fairly you can open
those I didn't know that here I was
being all like boos you're gonna open
that and be being stupid son of a [ __ ]
that I am didn't even try to explore
further
hey that's creepy whoa my wall climbing
ability is in question oh never mind
it's not and that's almost more
effective I wish I had more like a
shotgun type thing I feel like that
would be marginally more effective than
what I'm doing with this little piddly
poopy do people it
there we go you're not done yet find the
next cache you almost have what you need
hello okay all right sure whatever you
say buddy whatever you say enough
[Music]
probably not I don't know if there's
some kind of story think that's gonna
happen about this also its ranks and not
levels which Kirk's me because they look
like they're just levels not ranks they
look like levels but that is cool to the
gun levels with me in the way I don't
have to actually keep upgrading
constantly I'm fun hey pops that's been
pretty fun then what do you what do you
mean by that
look at my liver or something you're my
left testicle
why are you admitting these things to me
oh sure no I'm kind of hearing this guy
out here he's got some cool things to
say talk more about how sterile you are
and inadequate you are to my huge
manliness my incredibly handsome
features your old sterile disease-ridden
body is nothing in comparison to my
young vibrant body
[Music]
nothing nothing
there we go there we go my restraining
[ __ ] I was saying come on now you
know I'm big and strong even the green
just don't fear death maybe I'm just a
stone-cold badass you ever think about
that maybe a little bomb blown up in my
brain ain't gonna be so scary you stupid
idiot where am I going please get this
bomb out of me place your gun give this
palm out of a place right
for MRSA no no no about that you know
I'll take my time take my time and then
with no rush
what kind of failsafe doesn't blow up
right away nice ship hey buddy
oh come on now you're being all silly
are you being so silly gonna shower
money everywhere
that's my kind of that's my kind of
demise I think that's the point of the
thing right now I think it's uh well
those are two different things
was I supposed to be stealthy I don't
even know if I was and frankly being
stealthy seems kind of boring and slow
I like fast speedy stuff that's my kind
of jams and I'm jamming it up right now
all right
did that whatever that did you have a
choice you can well I'm a greedy son of
a [ __ ] well I'm a hero huh that's a
bomb all the bomb or whatever I don't
know
about precious time I'm real quick ok
can do how do I do that
whoa same way I've been doing everything
else okay Oh Oh God
Oh God where did that come from well
suddenly you're just gonna have this big
badass thing going on there I don't even
need to show you well finally someone's
gonna have put up some kind of a fight
but whatever okay can do I don't know
how to break in whooping I saw that
guy's face and we're break-in there
everything else I'm going Oh going is
what I am and isn't it like a tactically
advantageous thing to blow up one of
their specialist ships or capital ships
or whatever this is in relation to the
whole shebang I have no idea those cool
moves I'm doing right here one of these
days I'll actually go in a straight line
to you guys but right now I'm just gonna
whip rap all over the place that's I
have to hope they bang boom well [ __ ]
tipos are you talking about hey did I
get this thing out of my head oh here oh
I put that where did I go
- the navigation console mm-hmm charging
up you need to bring four down it's
smarter now you can capture you again
don't worry I will be with you let's
show him how much you have learned oh
hell yeah thank you whoever you are
mysterious lady ooh a squad we got a
squad okay I'm here I'm ready baby
hey nice actually not nice ship that is
hideously ugly yeah that one
yeah the wiggly one hey can I do that I
can I can wiggle worm my ship I hope
these guys can't hear me if you can hear
me I'm sorry so that's a shadow
oh god it's one of these losers okay oh
oh my bad sorry divine blood what about
my blood is divine what coupon the two
strings
it's just disintegrated it's as if it
was directly connected to four you're
done here go to extraction
look all done yes
my god this game is deep this game is in
depth it took me an hour to get through
just the tutorial and not that the
tutorial was any sort of like difficult
at all
I mean tutorials story mission whatever
yeah I'm free and it needs you it does
it needs me it's a dangerous time there
will be others too it is time for the
Tenno to return so next I don't know man
I don't know I think I'm gonna put a
pause to it for now the Knights bow
alright so we did the introductory
sequence and it was fun it was a good
introduction to the game but where do we
go from here now I've been told that I
need to make my way to Venus but I can't
go to Venus until I get four mods and
then upgrade those mods to Rank 2 or
higher through the fusion process now
the fusion I don't know what all that is
but that looks pretty cool anyway
believe me let me see if I can whoa
what's the dojo oh my god holy [ __ ]
Venus ok ah there's a lot more to this
game than I thought there was I need to
get to Fortuna that's my objective
that's my goal that's what I'm gonna do
right now so let me see what I can do as
far as installing new mod refuse
something in here
ha ha ah ha ha ah ha ha
apply fusion bang yes Oh greater than
the sum I did something using this
currency and a little bit of this
currency but not this currency just yet
so platinum is the main currency in this
game and it's used to speed up or rush
past the weight limits for these builds
probably as I level up I'm gonna get
longer and longer builds to take more
and more time now there's nothing in the
game where you can buy materials you
can't do that and that's what I like
about the game because it's not pay to
win the only thing that this can do is
help you speed up past this or buy new
frames I believe and new frames are the
things that make you look badass and
they all have different features and
functions as well which goes to make me
think what is me in this entire endeavor
what what am i exactly yeah whatever
alright let's see if I can equip some
mods how about my gun you probably do
yeah oh yeah
ok I can do that oh oh uh huh I thought
it good oh there we go that was easy I
didn't even know about that but that's
good ok good
I've got some mods upgrade this whatever
this is boink and boink okay good nice
nice nice
I don't know what I did but it sounded
nice let's see if what else I need to be
able to get to Venus just yet I need oh
no I'm ready
Venus Junction I guess I'm going to
Venus well I don't know what this is all
about
okay I wasn't gonna do anything about it
oh boy hey hey hey whoa oh whoa oh oh
whoa joy
where'd you go
Wow I thought I dodged that
I guess it might just be better to just
shoot him huh
stead of trying to be fancy and dancing
all over the place might be best to do
okay you're dead
well I am pretty pretty incredibly
amazing you won't see it undone well you
saw yourself undone you should let me do
what I was gonna do and you should have
shut up that's what you should have done
oh [ __ ]
oh that seems cool
or deadly oh ah that's what I did okay
but that means that I've made it to of
it Oh to Venus okay so I just need to
get through two more things and then
I'll get right to forth to you now ha ha
you can get fancy with the the matrix no
good day well I need to eliminate them
all so it's a little easier if they're
all out here what was that
there's a lot of cool things that I'm
gonna learn over time but I'm never
gonna be able to do right now but god
damn if this game isn't cool man these
kill missions ain't like other MMO skill
misses this is an extermination like I
am killing everybody and I guess it's
okay for some reason oh you mean I
should stop is that is that what you're
saying that you mean I should probably
probably stop okay I was good I feel
kind of bad for how much death and
destruction I I dealt out but you know
it is what it is is what it is okay next
stop is unda I got to go to a spy
mission oh okay a spy mission alright
okay a spy but should I'll be okay as by
buzzard okay don't tell nobody I'm here
okay
it's our little secret you between you
me and the ground you're lying on and
bleeding into oh just you wait
whoa I blew up a lot I don't think they
know though I think I don't think they
suspect nothing
hmm he'll put a nice secure fee nice
secure anybody nice security yeah yeah
okay yeah a nice security okay yeah nice
hey Pez easy give give give they won't
know about all the bodies and the
explosions they see that bunch of stupid
idiots all right let's go for it baby
let's go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I didn't mean that I didn't mean okay
here we go we're just gonna go for it
okay we can't all right we're just we're
just going for it we're just going for
it cuz I messed up
obviously I messed up I messed up on
this one hang on hang on hang on there
huh Oh God okay here we go here we go
here we go other side other side other
side door door door
okay oh [ __ ] me here we go and there we
go no data done look I didn't know that
there was anything going on with any
sort of anybody ow ow ow ow ow ah I'm
Audi I'm out it's subtle as the moon
hello were you waiting for me you
shouldn't have been goodbye goodbye
hello goodbye
oh oh easy easy easy peasy give me some
challenging come on who are you what are
you ain't nobody come on I think I
finally made my way to Fortuna I have
okay so this is what we've been going
for this is Fortuna oh [ __ ] oh let's go
to 212
I like Fortuna twelve that sounds pretty
good now this is an open world which
means that it's gonna be where all the
other players are so this is kind of
what it's been building
towards is hope
[Music]
he's a super robot head
what we this the song
you
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay hi can you stop staring at me
please
okay all right what the hell is this
place
why are you staring at me don't wave
that's just creepy what's with these
robos where they have Robo half who me
do they just have Robo arms is that the
only thing that Robo I don't know what's
going on - they just start replacing
pieces of the toes ah team [ __ ] David I
love that team that's my favorite team
all right who to call
I'm coming to the cow I'm coming who to
go hello Karis alright whatever
who to call ha hi it's me baby we work
for a living we don't need no trouble
and we don't need no one getting hurt
you can go buy something from Thursday
he's been staring down the barrel of a
repo order ever since he took on his
parents get
repo order the Loris falls too deep in
debt Neff sends in his repo squads to
take what he says he's owed you know
mechanical body parts even a full rig in
Thursday's case cuz you got none of that
they take the organics arms and legs
yeah there's a market for those too okay
all right man I'm sorry
hey I'm gonna go I'm gonna go - what was
his name who's your name Thursday sure
sure do Thursday I really do I would you
have like a shotgun yeah I suppose so
okay okay that's a good idea I am up for
that sort of thing I will go topside
thank you cuz I got no limitations I
can't die or plantations on my deck
there's a cycle right so selling useless
crap at the edge of a coolant canal
okay well okay there was a time [ __ ]
another name Vox Solaris the voice of
the resistance the voice of Solaris you
might it okay she stood up for us said
how wrong this all is she always said
Solaris United was all of us but it
weren't nothing without her when the
trouble happened
lefty tried to identify her why he did
to the others
what happened home Dec 12 she's always
been kind to me what happened to them
was never her fault
hey look hey listen man I I just wanted
to come by something I didn't mean to
get into this whole like rebel without a
cause thing and I I don't know I don't
know what's going on but anyway I'm
gonna go out here maybe I'm gonna get on
a team and maybe it's gonna be awesome
okay okay no I don't know I don't what
is welcome to Venus it'll kill ya what's
going on you keeping your nose clean
Utica sure I'm just giving up both
towards my shoddy boss here you know
learning a wage any way I can
or anything Busbee out will they get you
into trouble
mm-hmm Oh what was I whoa who shot me
does a lot of shoe sting I'm not gonna
be able to get across that am i uh-huh
okay crates full of the good stuff you
say good stuff huh okay mom good for the
good stuff
I'm looking for good stuff there's some
pippity poppity poops over there I think
they're shooting at me but you know I
don't need to worry about that because
I'm just way too brave for any of that
hello where am I what is this that's so
cool I'm climbing up it whatever it is
this is what I always do it like mmo's I
just find places that I can climb just
try to go as high as I can
it seems like a logical thing to do okay
I'm almost stopped I'm almost up here we
go here we go
there we go there we go there we go
there we go oh yeah the coolest thing oh
look at me what oh this is so cool Oh
what the hell ooh come on come on you
got this you got this baby
come on it's pretty sheer up this way
but you got this I know you do
oh god that's a little bit farther
you're so close
maybe a rest stop here I really hope
they didn't put like an artificial
ceiling on this because I want to go all
the way up there there's probably like
an elevator that goes straight up here
almost almost
and we're up we did it I don't know why
we did it
what we did it
ah that's so cool that's so cool I mean
there was no point to coming up here but
the fact that I could I don't know that
just tickles me that's my favorite part
about games like that oh god what is is
why is it so goofy and weird and melty
oh what's in here that's just a butthole
it's it's a bottle at the top of a tower
alright let's see if I can take fall
damage oh nothing okay alright
oh what's that something that looks like
something that's definitely some there
we go oh let you know I can find some
good stuff alright is this important
okay got them there's just one more
lying around somewhere how do I heal my
health that's what I don't know I've
taken quite a bit of health damage my
shields are fine but they were generate
I need it
it's melt soon what is that hello
chimera I'm coming for you I'm coming
for you baby oh my god that did some oh
[ __ ] well the faux
[ __ ] oh god I died it was the first time
I died that's okay
can I get my weapon out
now what the [ __ ]
it was like no warning before I die
neither it was just like dad okay got it
okay what are you thinking you want to
call this spy drone hearing what you're
up to too late so you can damn well help
what did i do what did i do what did I I
didn't do nothing guided to find the
drone before it reports back to Central
Command you got it buddy you got it baby
you got it baby you got it you you got
it I got it you got it you got it we got
it I got it you know got it we got it
okay we got something going on over here
huh okay
well I'm coming for you baby
[ __ ] maybe I shouldn't have just
coming in here Oh God yep I am in
trouble there's a lot of enemies here
what are you doing flying yeah so much
health whoa oh god okay I just gotta
kill this one I don't get to worry about
anything else
whoa okay nevermind I gotta worry about
everything else holy [ __ ] holy crap
I just gotta kill this drone that's all
I gotta worry about you help how much
health do you have oh come on I can't
hit you oh my god
come on
Oh God Oh God they're all around me oh
this is bad I gotta go I gotta go I
gotta go I gotta go sorry I got an
appointment I gotta go I gotta go I
gotta go I gotta go
come on oh it's so close it's so close
come on Oh God
AHA I got me but I'm very close just
gotta get this thing down Oh get out of
the way get out of the way please I just
want to kill this thing what what
reinforcements defeated oh oh okay I see
I see
wow those legs are spindly all right so
I got that oops that's not what I meant
to do whoa why are you no [ __ ] ah it's
that one flying guy he's like he's just
a son of a [ __ ] yeah
shock eczema s-- right okay I need to
pick them off one by one that's what I
gotta do
oh they're trying to kill the drone wait
oh okay Wow Jesus Oh what the [ __ ] oh
god okay this is good Brad there's
probably a way to heal but I just don't
know it at the moment if I knew it I'd
do it but I don't know it's I don't do
it I would really like a shotgun a
shotgun would be great
Oh God who shouldn't oh you all right
here we go come on come around that
corner come on
pistol does more damage than the frickin
rifle buzz oh not to this guy oh not to
this guy
whoop Oh God
Asuncion are there such a mix of levels
almost there almost there almost there
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's just the tough guys
I got I can't die again I can't die
again oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
I just need some not so tough guys
that's all I need you you guys you guys
look not so tough
there we go there we go there we go yes
yes no no no I gotta go I gotta go I
need to hide I'm not gonna take out as
many as I can because I I just want to
be out there all right
anyway I did that I probably was way
underleveled and way under geared for
that but I did it and that was frickin
fun is Fric oh sorry buddy look after
dealing what I just dealt with the
learning curve has has taken a toll on
me but I've learned only I knew how to
he holy [ __ ] that was awesome that was
awesome
so I did it am I am I good or do you
have even whoa that's a lot of people
nice sword
you make my stick look like a just a
piece of [ __ ] don't you well look at you
guys
well my man I'm just basic [ __ ] no skin
over here all right you guys you guys
look like you're so fun you guys look
fun I wish I was as fun as you guys
anyway over here then I guess whatever
hello how you doing I go to quest I
guess this is okay all right well
okay what have you do what is the room
just I was just posing it all time
oh all right anyway so that is just a
sampling of what Fortuna has one thing I
want to do because I'm it's not that I'm
jealous of everybody and how good they
look it's I just want to know that I can
also I want everybody else to know that
I also can look real good so what I want
to do now is I want to make myself look
as cool as I possibly can I am the
bubblegum blaster I also realize how
weird it is that I don't actually have a
face but that's okay I got a rhino horn
and that's all matters yeah but anyway
that is all I've got for this episode of
warfarin thank you everybody so much for
watching there is so much content in
this game that you can all experience
for free one of my favorite things about
it is it's a free game that's not pay to
win all of the like the purchases that
you can make in game are only for
cosmetic things you can never pay to
make yourself more powerful and that's
one of the best things about these games
pay to win is no way at all that make a
game because it just makes it unfair for
everybody so there's an entire solar
system of content to explore not just
here in Venus but all over the entire
solar system of all this different stuff
they update the game all the time most
recently is the Fortuna open-world stuff
I think and there's ton for you to
explore so if you want to check it out
for yourself there's a link in the
description down below you can download
the game free it's a big beefy download
but it's worth it in my honest opinion
this is an incredible game and I'm gonna
have a lot of fun playing it there's a
lot of stuff to do his endless adventure
there's a lot of other people and no no
it's space and I love space so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think down the comments
below if you play more frame yourself
and you think that I'm terrible at the
game let me know in the comments as well
or if you think I do a good start let me
know in the comments as well thank you
everybody so much for watching I'll see
you in the game and as always see you
video bye
[Music]